الاسبق نور الدين بدوي بتهم
الفساد. تحذيرات في بريطانيا
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
شاويش اوغلو يقول ان من الممكن
يزور ايران. فهل حان وقت الحوار
لحل الازمة? وهنا بعد ثلاثة اشهر
جاندي? الاحداث التركية تتطور.
بينما ينشغل العالم بحرب
غير مسبوق على كوريا الشمالية
حال اجراءها تجربة نووية جديدة
تعيين سفير لبلاده لدى القاهرة
خلال الاشهر القادمة وتحدث عن
المجاورة. مناورات جوية امريكية
اسرائيلية تحاكي ضرب المنشآت
للعلاقات مع الصين انتهى متعهدا
بتطوير موقف المملكة المتحدة من
الصين تمثل تحديا لهم بكيفية
التعامل وطبيعة العلاقات معها.
خارج المنطقة. ليصرح الجيش
الصيني ان افعال الجيش الامريكي
تنتهك بشكل خطير السيادة والامن
الصينيين. بينما ذكرت مجلة
مرة منذ اربعين عاما. ورعب في
هاواي والسلطات تحذر المناطق
انفلات امني سببه لصوص مسلحون.
اكبر برك في العالم يثور لاول
بكين. وبرغم قوله ان علاقات
بريطانيا كانت ساذجة مع بكين
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسون
قائلا ان ما يسمى بالعصر الذهبي
هذا الرد الهزيل من الامريكيين
برأيكم? تحركات الاتراك تتواصل
بكين يقول اذا اقتربتم مرة اخرى
من حدودنا الاقليمية فلن تجدوا
من اصحاب العيون الضيقة. لتستشيط
واشنطن غضبا وهي التي تدفع
بينما المانيا تقوض اهداف الوحدة
الغربية نحو الصين بتقربها اكثر
النووية الايرانية. الصين توجه
ضربة قوية لسفن امريكا ولسان حال
لقاءات على مستوى وزاري ستعقد
قريبا بين البلدين. بينما تحدثت
من اي نوع حسب وكالة يوناب. بعد
التوترات الاخيرة على الحدود
من ايداعه الحبس المؤقت. القضاء
الجزائري يحاكم رئيس الوزراء
العراقية الايرانية هو رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني
طرادا امريكيا دخل بشكل غير
قانوني الى المياه القريبة من
للمواطنين والسياح في لندن من
ارتداء مقتنيات ثمينة بسبب
من قبل في السياسة لا عدو دائم
ولا صديق دائم. الاحداث
انقرة بداية فراجة لحل الازمة
السياسية بين مصر وتركيا. هنا
اوكرانيا ومجاعة الغرب للطاقة من
اجل الشتاء المارد العثماني لا
الى معارضة بلاده لمواصلة اي حرب
توقع المدنيين الضحايا. فلماذا
فانه قد حذر من خطاب الحرب
الباردة. مشددا على ان الاهمية
الحلفاء الاوروبيين الى اتخاذ
موقف اكثر تجاه الصين. ليخرج
جزر سبراتلي في بحر الصين
الجنوبي. وانه راقب الطراد لدى
بوليتكو وجود خلافات حادة داخل
حلف الناتو حول كيف التعامل مع
والتطورات. تعهد رئيس كوريا
الجنوبية يونسيو كيول برد مشترك
لانهاء الازمة في اوكرانيا وحمل
الكرملين اوكرانيا مسؤولية عرقلة
مقابل تصنيف روسيا لا سيما بعد
تسريب حديث لوسائل الاعلام
العالمية للصين لا يمكن فبماذا
سترد بكين على تصريحات حفيد
عقدا مع المانيا لتصدير الغاز
ابتداء من الفين وستة وعشرين.
مصادر اخبارية عن لقاءات
لاستخبارات البلدين. وقد اعلنها
دخوله ليتم التدخل فورا وابعاده
بواسطة اطلاق طراد صواريخ الى
لاتخاذ خطوات لحماية اراضيها لا
نقبل المحاسبة وسنواصل عملياتنا
جون كيربي ان من حق تركيا ان
تدافع عن نفسها. غير انه اشار
ضد الارهاب. ليرد منسق الاتصالات
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
يتوقف. ها هو اردوغان يعلنها
قائلا ان بلاده لن تستأذن اي احد
نعم المانيا لم تعد بحاجة
للامريكان حيث وقعت قطر للطاقة
الصين. وكانت المجلة قد قالت ان
اعضاء الحلف قد اتفقوا على ان
كازاخستان والجزائر واوزباكستان
لدعم الشحنات بين الدول الثلاث
بحسب القيادة الجنوبية للجيش
لينصح الرئيس الاوكراني شعبه بان
التفاوض. فهل حان وقت الصلحية
هؤلاء? الصين ترد عسكريا. ما
سلاح الشتاء. وعلى لسان رئيس
الحلف الذي صرح قائلا روسيا تفشل
قوات روسيا قصفت خرسون بمائتين
وثمانية وخمسين صاروخا الاسبوع
ومشترين اخرين للطاقة من بينهم
الصين لمواجهة قرار الغرب بشأن
لامريكا لكنها هذه المرة عسكرية.
حيث اعلن الجيش الصيني انه ابعد
حيث خرجت الاحتجاجات في المانيا
مطالبة برحيل الاحتلال الامريكي
لتعويض الروس عن الزبائن
الغربيين? وهنا يظهر خلاف اخر
بالتخلص من الاسلحة الامريكية
باعتبار انها تجرهم الى الحرب.
من بلادهم المتمثل بالقواعد في
اراضيهم. كما طالب المحتجون
حتى تنفذ الصواريخ من موسكو. وهل
يخلو البحر من الماء? بينما
ومعدات عسكرية جديدة لاوكرانيا.
ليرد الالمان بطريقتهم الخاصة
العسكرية لاوكرانيا عام المقبل
ومواجهة المنافسين الدوليين ليس
نوع كاليبر وهذا يشير الى ان
هناك استعدادات جارية لشيء ما
وهنا الكرملين يرحب بعرض
الفاتيكان القيام بوساطة للتفاوض
الاوكرانيين. انها حاملة صواريخ
سطح التي تحمل ثمانية صواريخ من
الذين يعبرون الى بقية اوروبا.
سلاح اخر اظهره بوتين ليرعب به
جديدة والناتو اوروبا وموسكو
تعلن عن اتحاد جديد يضم دولة
يتعهد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
سوناك بمواصلة او زيادة المساعدة
الى الاتصالات الجديدة بين
البلدين? وهل امريكا الاوروبيين
حذرت منه بكين بالامس ها هو يحدث
اليوم وضربة اخرى من الصينيين
حرب الطاقة العالمية. هنا اعلنت
روسيا عن اتحاد الغاز مع
بالكلام الرنان ولكن بواقعية
قوية. ومن الحرب الاوكرانية الى
ليخرج حلف الناتو ويحذر من سلاح
بوتين الجديد لحسم الحرب الا وهو
بين امريكا واوروبا حيث اكدت
المندوبة الامريكية لدى الناتو
عكسية. فهل يكون هذا الموقف
اللين من واشنطن تجاه موسكو يعود
الغربية ان وزراء خارجية دول
الناتو يجتمعون لبحث توفير اسلحة
جوليمن سميث ان تصنيف روسيا دولة
راعية للارهاب قد يكون له نتائج
ينتظر اسبوعا وحشيا اخر من البرد
والظلام. متوقعا المزيد من
تحديد سقف لسعر الطاقة الروسي
فهل يكون هذا الاتحاد كافيا
في حربها على اوكرانيا ودولنا
تدفع ثمنا باهظا جراء حرب كما
الهجمات الروسية على البنية
التحتية قائلا الهجمات لن تتوقف
حذر اعضاء الحلف بقوله علينا ان
نكون مستعدين لمزيد من اللاجئين
عربية لمواجهة الغرب. فيما
اردوغان يتحدى الجميع. تسريبات
بالمناورة والدفاع. ليخرج الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي مصرحا ان
غير هذه الصواريخ في انتظاركم.
على انفسهم. والجزائر تحاكم
فاسديها بينما يتفاوض العراق مع
الى اجل غير مسمى والروس يكثفون
هجماتهم والاوكران يستمرون
لموسكو قوات كييف بنشر جنود
استعدادا لاقتحام المحطة النووية
الماضي والقصف الروسي لا يتوقف
عن بينما اتهمت القوات الموالية
ايران. زلزال روسي وسط اوكرانيا.
انها حامية الوطيس. والحرب تمتد
الجنوبية تتحدى مجنون جارتها
الشمالية وفي لندن لا يأمن الناس
تفيد باجتماع الاستخبارات
المصرية والتركية وكوريا
حالة من الدور لساعات والزينسكي
يستغيث بينما بوتين يشهر اسلحة
تغرق اوكرانيا بكمية صواريخ
هائلة جعلت الاوكرانيين يعيشون
تهرول بقوتها تجاه سفينة امريكية
بالصواريخ فما الذي يجري وروسيا